I finally got around to watching Firefly
let's talk about that welcome to
Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and movie
channel
[Music]
before we get into this video I'd like
to invite you to subscribe to my
personal YouTube channel Matt's nerd
corner where I talk about everything
nerdy might be Stargate it might be
doctor who might be comic books
basically whatever I'm passionate about
that's where I'm going to talk about it
check the first link in the description
and subscribe to my YouTube channel so a
couple of weeks ago on the side track
live it became apparent that I've not
really seen that many TV shows or movies
with regards to sci-fi now I have
watched sci-fi shows obviously I'm a
massive fan of Stargate Doctor Who and
various other shows however I tend to
stick to the shows that I know and love
and haven't really branched out into
some of the top favorites of fans
one show that was always recommended to
me over and over again was Firefly
and I just had to watch it I have
completed the season and I have some
thoughts initial reaction to the first
episode was wow what an episode the
pilot episode is probably the best pilot
I've ever seen on any television show
ever the first 10 minutes or so I was a
little bit like eh I don't really get
this and I don't know why anyone really
likes it
but then it all kicked off we get to
meet all of the characters in The Pilot
obviously it's a pilot episode and
honestly my first reaction for Malcolm
Reynolds was I absolutely hate this guy
who is he and who does he think he is
because he does not seem like a likable
character at all he came across as a
cold-hearted callous man with no regard
for anyone else one thing I did notice
about him was he had this aversion to
religion even though in the first 10
minutes of the episode we see him
holding across now having watched the
entire series now I believe he has a
character detached himself from God
after the war had failed and his side
had essentially lost I got to see more
of this man as the series went on and
and I realized whilst he is borderline
insane he's also very loyal to his crew
furthermore he cares about the people
that he encounters he always airs on the
side of righteousness even though he is
technically a criminal space pirate he
always wants to do right thing he always
wants to protect the weak and although
his chosen line of work isn't very
honorable he does have a strict code of
honor that he follows himself
so my first impressions whilst I didn't
really like the character as the series
went on I absolutely loved him the other
character that really surprised me
really was the character of Kaylee as
well someone who the actress I'd already
seen in Stargate Atlantis as Dr Jennifer
Keller when I first saw the character of
Kaylee I wasn't very impressed at first
glance she seems a little young naive
and a little bit annoying however as the
series went on I fell in love with her
character she's an extremely passionate
person a highly skilled engineer and
someone who wears their heart on their
sleeve she wants to find love and even
develops a crush on the doctor however
she isn't afraid to speak her mind
specifically around the areas of feeling
inadequate and underappreciated she
knows her worth she knows what she has
to offer and although she wants to find
love she's not going to take crap from
any man I absolutely love Kaylee now
she's easily one of my favorite
characters let's talk about Shepard this
character is surrounded in mystery and I
haven't seen Serenity yet but we don't
really get to know that much about him
there's a lot of mysteries surrounding
this guy he claims to be a holy man a
man of God a Shepherd but seems to have
an unusual amount of knowledge
surrounding Weaponry the types of
weapons bullets things like that and
also
he's a really good fighter now that's
not something you would really attribute
to a man of God something that became
apparent during the series as well was
he also seemed to have a past with the
alliance having quite a high status with
them in the fifth episode he gets
wounded and Malcolm has to basically
take him to an alliance hospital he's
turned away at first but as soon as
Shepherd's identity card gets shown he's
let straight through
and we never really find out why there's
always random lines of dialogue from him
as well things that seem really out of
character which to me suggests that he's
leading some sort of double life one
Theory I have is that perhaps he turned
to God for atonement after the life he'd
previously LED he needed some sort of
religious cleansing one of the first
lines he ever says in the show was that
he never married as well that to me
suggests that he was in his previous
life someone who traveled around a lot
never stayed in one place long enough to
settle down
but maybe I'm reading too much into it
the rest of the characters in Firefly I
absolutely love one notable person I
have to mention is anara anara
the actress again I first saw in
Stargate if you played Adria you know
the RSI for the aurai and I fell in love
we were in Stargate but I fell in love
with her even more in Firefly cheers for
all intents and purposes uh prostitute
she's a companion who essentially picks
who she wants to sleep with
and she's a very high class very
emotional very
she's the kind of person who wants to
get to know her clients and give them a
really good experience because it's to
her it's about meeting the people and
having
a connection something that's really
apparent with her and Malcolm is that
there's a lot of unspoken feelings
towards each other which is never really
said the second to last episode they go
to a planet which is essentially a
prostitute brothel I'm not going to say
that the the W word because we might get
demonetized but it's essentially it's
essentially one of those places where
lots of women of that nature congregate
and Malcolm ends up sleeping with the
head lady but she ends up ultimately
dying and Malcolm realizes he wants to
share his feelings for an arrow who who
doesn't really give him chance to
express his feelings in fact she says
that she's going to leave Serenity Now
you can see the Heartbreak in his eyes
when this happens
but I genuinely believe that them too if
the show had went on would have
eventually got together maybe they do in
the movie I don't know I've not seen it
yet I can't find it anywhere but I will
find it and I will watch it there are
loads more characters in this show that
I could talk about we have Simon and
river and
Zoe and wash and even Jane Jane is one
of those characters oh my God I hated
him when I first met him then I started
to kind of like him and then I hated him
all over again and then at the end I
kind of liked him he's just one he was a
rollercoaster of a character to get my
head around because he he always wanted
to double cross the captain he always
wanted to get money that was that was
his pure motivation in the episode
Jamestown when all of the people thought
he was a hero because he accidentally
dropped the money out you kind of saw a
side of him that was like yeah I kind of
want to be the hero and then he turned
very very quickly at the end and he even
tried to double cross the captain once
more after that he's a very complicated
character and someone who I really
really struggled to like but there were
moments in the show where I really liked
him but mostly I absolutely hated him
let's talk about River now river is a
very interesting character and probably
the main character of the show you can
probably argue that a lot of the stories
are centered around her
she's a very intelligent woman she
was essentially a genius growing up and
she was taken by the alliance and
experimented on and now she can just
feel every emotion because they took
something out of their brain but she can
also seem to
control the [__] with her mind
that was something that was weird but
she can also seem to predict the future
she and she can just tell things about
people without ever actually talking to
them which is really really cool and
interesting I love that in science
fiction there's always that that
character who has these special
abilities and you you never really know
why uh we don't we don't know why
specifically in Firefly because the show
was canceled but I would love if they
rebooted or renewed to explore that
character more in depth because that is
such an interesting character to me I
love those kinds of characters let's
talk about Kaylee and Simon I mentioned
when I was talking about Kayla that she
doesn't take crap from any man who
doesn't appreciate her and there was a
lot of will they get together won't they
get together and although they
definitely both had a crush on each
other the kind of thing Simon was coming
out with really didn't sit well with
Kaylee and she wasn't afraid to just say
look
you don't appreciate me you only want me
because I'm the only one here that's
basically what you're saying to me and
she didn't take any crap from him I
genuinely believe that they will get
together if the show was ever to
continue or they rebooted or whatever
they would get together because they
would make a really good pair he is a
very awkward man he doesn't know how to
talk to women and I think that's where
he trips himself up a lot of the time
she as I mentioned is someone who wears
her heart on her sleeve and she just
says how she feels and he doesn't know
how to express himself and often when he
does try to express himself he gets it
wrong and offends her
and that is that is a problem when
you're trying to court someone in a
relationship overall
I really really liked Firefly I'm
actually on my second watch through of
it right now and
I'm gonna try and find the movie
Serenity at some point try and find it
so I can actually get
some answers uh or some sort of
conclusion I don't think there's going
to be any satisfying conclusion to
Firefly
I really hope at some point they renew
or reboot or whatever it is they decide
to do because this show has been off the
air for 20 years and I've only just got
around to watching it but I already want
more
I can't imagine how it's been for
everyone else who watched it 20 years
ago and has been pining for this show
ever since the next show I'm going to
watch is Babylon 5 as has been
recommended to me so many times and I
know there's more than one season of
That So I'm very very excited
but do you have any other
recommendations for television shows let
me know in the comment section down
below whilst you're down there hit like
And subscribe and press the Bell
notification so you don't miss a single
video thank you so much for watching my
name is Matt and I'll see you next time
foreign